mikro roboter bevölkern den menschlichen
körper neue methode um den mars zu
erreichen entdeckt und durchbruch bei
der quanten teleportation das sind drei
der 15
heute bei den klick zum top five news
mikro roboter bevölkern den menschlichen
körper den wissenschaftlern des
max-planck-instituts in stuttgart ist es
gelungen so genannte micro schwimmer
herzustellen
die klein genug sind um in den venen des
menschlichen körpers zwischen
blutkörperchen zu schwimmen
die mini roboter könnten in zukunft dazu
genutzt werden medikamente zielgenau zu
den stellen im körper zu liefern
an denen sie gebraucht werden sie
könnten außerdem bei der diagnose helfen
indem sie proben liefern an die die
ärzte ohne eine operation gar nicht
daran kommen würden die technik beruht
auf zwei silikon polymer schalen die mit
einem drehgelenk verbunden sind und sich
wie eine muschel fortbewegen
die einzelteile dieser roboter wurden in
einem spezial 3d drucker hergestellt das
gelenk eines roboters ist gerade einmal
0,6 millimeter dicker wird es ist
wirklich kaum zu sehen
legt werden die mikro schwimmer mit
hilfe von sogenannten seltenen erden
magneten also micro magneten und eines
magnetfeldes auf diese weise kann der
arzt bestimmen zu exakt welcher stelle
im körper sich die mikro roboter bewegen
sollen neue methode um zum mars zu
fliegen
der wissenschaftler etwa wenn bruno hat
eine methode gefunden um
energiesparender unflexibler zum mars zu
fliegen
das sogenannte ballistische anfang wurde
1991 von den japanern das erste mal
benutzt um auf dem mond zu landen
auch damals schon vor über 20 jahren war
es etwas bel bruno der die idee zu der
neuartigen methode hatte nach dem erfolg
wollte auf diese weise auch auf dem mars
und noch viele weitere planeten kommen
gab dann aber auf zu kompliziert seien
die berechnungen für den roten planeten
gewesen doch jetzt 23 jahre später ist
ihm der durchbruch gelungen anders als
bei üblichen flugblättern wird das
raumschiff nicht direkt auf dem mars
geschossen sondern quasi in die laufbahn
des planeten gelupft dabei hilft der
planet mit seiner anziehungskraft und
ersetzt so ein teil der energie die man
nun nicht mehr als kraftstoff mitführen
muss außerdem sind die raumfahrer mit
dieser methode nicht mehr darauf an
diesen bestimmte zeitfenster einzuhalten
man könnte so viel flexibler zum mars
fliegen und auch wieder zurückkehren
ohne auf bestimmte planetenkonstellation
achten zu müssen
der einzige nachteil die flugzeit erhöht
sich damit eignet sich diese methode
ganz besonders gut zum um
arbeitsmaterial zu transportieren und
denn dieser dieser macht dann auch die
die erhöhte strahlung durch die längere
flugdauer nichts aus und die nasa ist
extrem davon überzeugt von dieser
methode das hat uns die augen geöffnet
sagt jim green chef der abteilung für
planetare wissenschaften bei der nasa
schon im nächsten jahrzehnt könnten wir
diese methode austesten neuer rekord bei
quanten teleportation ein forscherteam
der nasa hat es geschafft eine kranken
teleportation über die rekordstrecke von
25 kilometern durchzuführen damit kommen
wir der firma kann geschützte
kommunikation über weite strecken ein
großes stück näher
bei der kanten teleportation werden zwei
einzelne lichtteilchen also photonen
miteinander verschränkt ab diesem
zeitpunkt besitzen die beiden immer
denselben status auch wenn sie über
diesen versuch über 25 kilometer
entfernt sind wird jetzt eines der
beiden photonen zum beispiel mit einem
dritten beschossen und ändert sich
dadurch der status des ersten fotos
verändert sich zeitgleich auch der des
weit entfernten photons die
informationen wurde ohne zeitverzögerung
und ohne irgendeine uns bekannte
verbindung zwischen den beiden
übertragen leider kommen wie so oft
komplikationen hinzu um das zweite foto
auslösen zu können benötigt man zwei
kleine informationen die man über den
herkömmlichen weg also zum beispiel per
internet verschickt nur mit diesen
informationen kann man den status
auslesen
außerdem wird der status eines photons
beim auslesen geändert man kann also
leider nicht ohne zeitverzögerung von
deutschland nach einem
oder von der erde zum mars telefonieren
aber die kleinen informationen die man
zusätzlich verschicken muss können nicht
auf den status des foto- und schließen
schließen lassen somit ist der
kommunikationsweg absolut abhörsicher
die chinesen hatten das ja bereits 2012
bei ihrem 18
kongress der kommunistischen partei
erfolgreich angewendet keinerlei
informationen drang damals nach außen us
navy präsentiert laserkanonen das 40
jahre alte transportschiff uss ponce der
amerikanischen marine ist das erste
kriegsschiff das mit einem hochenergie
laser ausgestattet wurde
das laser meppen system schießt einen 30
kilowatt laser mit extremer präzision
auf weit entfernte ziele
die waffe soll laut der us navy vor
allem für den kampf gegen unbemannte und
kleine drohnen dienen diese fliegen
meist sehr hoch und sind für
kampfschiffe nur sehr schwer zu treffen
außerdem sei die laserwaffe sehr günstig
ein schuss kostet dabei weniger als
einen dollar obwohl das gesamte system
als 30 millionen dollar kostet wäre das
laut us navy immer noch kostengünstiger
als herkömmliche abwehrraketen die test
ergebnisse haben die erwartungen der
offiziere bei weitem übertroffen
der einsatz dieser laser galt bisher als
zu umständlich
die erforderte energieleistung um auf
distanz schaden anzurichten ist enorm
groß
außerdem könnten feinde durch den
einsatz von reflektierenden schilden die
waffe sehr einfach umgehen anders als
passant fiction film sieht und hört man
von der kanone beim abfeuern nicht nur
der einschlag auf dem ziel löste eine
explosion aus und richtet sichtlichen
schaden an auch der einsatz dieser waffe
gegen eine drohne wurde getestet
auch diese wurde präzise getroffen und
ist abgestürzt die soldaten verwendeten
dazu ein controller dem der dem einer
herkömmlichen spielkonsole stark ähnelt
3d revolution im weltraum zum ersten mal
wurde ein werkzeug per e mail an die
internationale raumstation iss geschickt
dort fehlte eine vierkant ratsche hier
auf der erde wurde das werkzeug designt
und der bauplan dann per mail an die iss
geschickt dort steht seit kurzem ein 3d
drucker in vier stunden druckte er das
werkzeug aus und astronaut perry moore
konnte das werkzeug sofort benutzen und
eine reparatur durchführen
zwei premieren wurden so gefeiert zum
ersten mal wurde ein werkzeug auf die
iss gemailt und zudem ist dieses
werkzeug selbst eine premiere
das gab es nämlich in der form noch
nicht wer schon stolzer besitzer eines
3d druckers ist kann sich den plan
übrigens herunterladen und das werkzeug
selbst drucken wenn es jemand schafft
schickt mir bitte das bild oder einen
link per facebook twitter instagram oder
mir wollt das foto kommt dann die
nächsten top five los link zum bauplan
gibt es in der video beschreibung eine
wolkenstadt der nasa das ist tatsächlich
auf der venus in planung ist der link
zum video und natürlich geht es hier
unten wie immer zu rap und zum blog und
jetzt bin ich natürlich extrem auf eure
meinung zu einem thema gespannt würdet
ihr mikro roboter in euren körper lassen
oder habt ihr angst vor diesen mikrochip
diskutiert es wie immer mit mir in den
kommentaren allerdings auch in der genau
in der video beschreibung und auch
natürlich der zum ratschen plan ich
verabschiede mich bis dann